which brings us to the category of Best
Picture and to present this most prized
award we are fortunate to have three
filmmakers of considerable distinction
John Huston
Billy Wilder
and akira kurosawa
the nominees for the best pictures are
the color purple a Warner Brothers
production one about us Steven Spielberg
Kathleen Kennedy Frank Marshall and
Quincy Jones producers
kiss of the Spider Woman an HP Films
production in association with sugarloaf
films Island Ally David Weissman
produced
out of Africa unite Universal Pictures
limited production Universal Sydney hog
producer
Griffith Anna an ABC motion picture
production 20th Century Fox producer
witless an Edward s Feldman production
paramount Edward s spelled introduced
- envelope please
the one is out of Africa
this is a wonderful evening for all of
us I just don't know what else to say
but thank you so much and if I left out
anybody before I I hope you'll
understand it was because of Awesome
pressure thank you very very much thank
you